- On this episode, I talk about my Pops,
I drill someone directly in
the face for a crap question,
and I really focus on what
small businesses should be doing
with itsy, bitsy cash.
(techno music)
Hello everybody and
welcome to episode three
of #AskGaryVee.
I'm really enjoying the
show, I hope you are as well,
and let's get right into question #1,
but first, actually, you
know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna do a tidbit about
every number, the number three,
my favorite roulette number.
It's my mom's birthday. I love you mom.
- [Voiceover] Brandon asks,
"Hey Gary V, what are the most
"important lessons your
father Sasha taught you
"about building a business?"
You know, Sasha's taught
me a bunch of stuff.
Some that I like to
keep, some that I kind of
push to the side, right Dad?
You know, this is a very
easy question for me.
Who asked that question?
- [Voiceover] Brandon Upley.
- Brandon, Brandon, that's very easy.
This, my dad taught me word is bond.
I've said a couple times
for the people that
watch me a lot, they know
this, that when I walked
into my dad's business at
14, let's just say I was
a little bit of a bullshit
artist and a lot of the charisma
and the showmanship and the salesmanship
that a lot of you enjoy,
and I appreciate that,
also comes with being full of crap.
It's got a very similar
cousin DNA and I'm glad I got
very lucky, let's call it
what it is, I do not think
I'd be as honorable or as good
of a dude without my dad's
correction of you make
of, I never forget it,
you make a commitment, you
buy, when I started buying wine,
you buy 50 cases, no matter
what, you take those 50 cases.
If you say I'll take 50
cases, if the market changes,
if it gets an 84 in the
Wine Spectator, you take it,
you eat it, you drink
it, your word is bond
and because I play the
marathon, not the sprint,
long-term businessman,
that's helped me a lot
because I've kept
relationships forever because
sticking to it has mattered
quite a bit, so thanks Dad
and thanks Brandon for the question.
- [Voiceover] Jeff asks,
"Where do you see yourself
"in five years?"
Jeff, the truth is, I
don't really see myself
anywhere in five years.
I am not a planner, I do
not have a five-year plan,
I think all of us can
agree that five years ago,
Instagram and Snapchat
didn't exist. You know, GoPro,
Netflix wasn't what it is today.
I mean, the world is
changing way too much for me
to think where I'm gonna be
in five years professionally.
Five years personally, I
will be in better shape,
I will spend more time with
my family. I will be going to
a lot of lacrosse games,
and ballets, and shows,
just trying to hack my life
to have a better balance.
Professionally, I will be
doing what I always do,
DRock, zoom on this ear, I
want you to go right in there.
My friend, this ear will be
listening to the market place.
I will be listening to the
market place and I will be
adjusting on the fly in
real time and I will be
running a business and
marketing like it's 2017,
like it's 2019, like it's
2022, like it's 2027,
I'm a reactionary, what I like to call,
I am a half-time adjustments head coach.
My game plan is okay going
into the game, I'm down 21-3
at halftime, I've got 15
minutes, I reverse, drop down,
flip it and reverse it, I
come out and I win 27-24.
That is who I am as an
entrepreneur, that is why
I have no idea what I will
be doing or how I see myself
professionally in five years.
- [Voiceover] Ben asks,
"Heading to New York City
"for the first time in September.
"What wine bar or restaurant
would you recommend?"
Ben, thanks for the props
on Resy, zoom in DRock.
Any of these lovely
establishments that have been
smart enough to join the
fray, Gotham Bar and Grill,
Rosemary's, Minetta Tavern, Toro, Estela,
Charlie Bird, Balthazar, all great choices
so I highly recommend
that and off the app,
as a wine bar, I'm a huge Terroir fan.
Stunwin, you're into the
wine game a little bit,
quite a bit, you're
passionate. Any wine bars,
you kind of, give 'em a little face time.
- Corkbuzz, Corkbuzz is good.
I like Terroir a lot as well.
- You know, to me, it's Terroir, Corkbuzz,
those are two spots to most focus on.
- [Voiceover] Scott asks,
"What's your number one
"piece of advice for
marketing a lean, local,
"city-based social start up?"
When we asked for more
details, he responded that
the product isn't fully
developed, however,
it's social marketing for my city only.
Scottie, listen, I took
this question because you
tweeted that you wouldn't eat
until I answered your question
and knowing that eating is important,
I wanted to deliver for you,
but I've gotta be honest
with you and I love you,
brother, and you know who I am,
you're watching the show,
so you asked the question.
I hate your question.
It's a ludicrous thing to
think about at this point
because the product's not even developed,
yet you're worried about marketing.
I'd love for you to develop the product,
taste it a little bit, cut
it back to question # 2 or 3
where, you know, you've gotta feel it,
you've gotta put it out in the wild,
reverse engineer it a little bit.
You know, my city only,
like local, there's a ton
of things you can do,
Facebook dark posts, tweets,
geolocation stuff, there's
a ton of things to do,
mobile ad stuff. There's
just an enormous amount
of flexibility on how to drill
it with a local business,
but the truth is, you're
getting ahead of yourself.
This is, you know, I don't
wanna dis or something
and I don't wanna dis 'cause I love you.
It's a little bit of
an amateurish question.
I need you to kind of get the
app out or the product out.
You're just getting way
too ahead of yourself.
The marketing will matter
only if the product
is serviceable at some level.
Great products always
need less great marketing
and great marketing
doesn't fix crap products.
- [Voiceover] What's your
advice for small business owners
with limited budgets?
Is it some local listings in SEO,
writing content, social media?
Antoine, what's up, brother?
Gary Vee, but you know that.
You know, look this is
always the best question.
This is the question that
I rappled with, rappled,
grappled with, when I got
involved in my dad's business.
It's very hard. What do you do?
I made flyers at home and
gave them out when people
walked into the store.
When you're hustling and
you've got limited budget,
you're in trouble by many
people's points of view.
Let me give you the real first answer.
The real first answer is work more.
The greatest way to
close the gap financially
is to put in the extra two or three hours.
So, whatever you're doing, add
an hour or two to each day.
Still eat healthy, still have
sleep, but an hour or two
of hustle, little less watching
Game of Throne marathons
and Madden 15, extra hustle
because when you're limited,
that's the play.
To me, Facebook dark
posts has one of the best
ROI's right now, Google AdWords is always
a strong contender, banner retargeting.
It really depends on your
business, it depends on
if you're e-commerce, to me,
those three would really work.
If you're a local business
that's trying to drive people
into the store, you start
looking at Yelp and Foursquare
and things of that nature.
Sometimes it might even
be, believe it or not,
local radio, local cable
television, believe it or not.
There might be ways, but the
truth is, there's very specific
answers based on very
specific small businesses.
But, don't, don't lack hustle.
Biz dev, one of my favorite things when we
didn't have a lot of dollars was biz dev.
Go to the barber and be
like, can I put some flyers
of my business in your store
and then you can put some,
there's that move. There's
the call for advertisers thing
that was my classic YouTube video.
We can link that down below,
that's probably the second time
in three episodes linking
it, but it's a classic.
Go and get the money, and so,
those would be my first answers to a local
financially strapped.
Networking, hustling, biz
dev'ing, go to the local
businesses around you, trade,
go to the Chamber of Commerce
events, figure out if you can do something
and just print coupons and hand them out,
you know, in quotes.
Guys, I appreciate you jamming
with me in episode three.
I'm really enjoying this, I
haven't done a regular show
since 2011, I'm enjoying
myself quite a bit.
If you wanna ask me a
question, use the hash tag
#AskGaryVee on Twitter and
we'll get you on the show.
It should be your life
dream to get your question
on the show.
You with a little bit of me,
we are changing the Q and A world.
(techno music)